et ce matin cet invité ses vous valérie
igounet bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes
avec nous virtuellement vous êtes
historienne politologue spécialiste du
négationnisme et alors avec l'écrivain
jacques schwartzmann le dessinateur lara
l'auteur morgan navarro vous venez de
signer ce livre ils sont partout aux
éditions les arènes bd est une bande
dessinée dont qui vient de sortir et qui
décortique le complotisme ou plutôt les
complotistes racontez moi d'abord
l'histoire c'est celle d'une jeune
journaliste qui réalise que que son
frère est en train de partir à la dérive
oui c'est tout à fait ça on fait elle se
rend compte que son frère est en train
de sombrer dans le complotisme et avec
ses parents on va dire si tu paies et au
fur et à mesure elle va est aidé en fait
par un journaliste un vieux briscard de
l'extrême droite et non seulement elle
va découvrir ce monde j'allais dire avec
effroi mais ils vont retrouver
on peut dire quoi non je ne dis rien
pour la fin du casse mais c'est un liste
une histoire du complotisme fictionnel
qui en fait reprend en grande partie la
réalité et qui met au jour plusieurs
thèses conspirationnistes bons échos
comment vous est venue l'idée d'ailleurs
de ce livre par rapport à des faits
d'actualité hallyday ont fait lé
j'allais dire assez simple
avait déjà j'avais déjà écrit un bouquin
aux arènes avec vincent jay russell une
vision nationale l'éditeur nous en avons
parlé on peut dire que le contexte on
était en 2017 2018 était déjà propice au
conspirationnisme et c'est vrai qu'au
fur et à mesure de la rédaction
dessin et cetera on s'est dit que
c'était vraiment j'allais dire hélas une
bonne idée et en adéquation avec
l'époque que nous jugions évidemment
alors on parlait du du procès des
attentats du 13 novembre l'histoire son
frère qui sont dans l'extrême droite a
pu être aussi celle d'un frère qui
compte faire le djihad c'est un peu le
même schéma d'embrigadement d'ailleurs
au fait une sorte d'inventaire des
complotistes ya un glossaire à la fin du
livre une sorte de deux festivals aussi
la vôtre bd qui réunit toutes sortes de
négationniste on y retrouve des des
néonazis ceux qui pensent que la terre
est plate ceux qui croient que le 11
septembre d'un coup les services secrets
américains ceux qui pensent que ce
panache de fumée dans le moteur les
avions c'est des produits chimiques on
retrouve les antilles vax le vaccin
qu'ovide 5 g qu'est ce qu'ils ont en
commun tous et complotistes le fait
qu'ils se disent tous anti système
alors c'est ce qu'on a d'ailleurs mis en
avant dans un bus un quelqu'un qui
explique d'ailleurs qu'il est anti
système oui et puis ils ont plus qu'un
doute j'allais dire vis-à-vis de cette
démocratie dans laquelle ils vivent quoi
c'est à dire que le monde la société les
troncs virtuellement quoi et qu'il faut
absolument trouver d'autres schémas de
pensée les adopter pour justement s'y
confronter et s'y oppose et surtout donc
c'est vrai que il y à des théories du
complot qui peuvent faire sourire
j'allais dire comme le plat tisme qui
sont exposés qui est exposé dans la bd
mais comme vous dites aussi il y en
ad'autres 1 je pense particulièrement au
grand remplacement au survivalisme c'est
un embrigadement qui peut
a mené à la mort ou à l'assassinât ce
qui est surprenant c'est qu'il ya des
liens entre parfois des complotisme qui
ont l'air complètement
divergents enfin pas du tout sur la même
femme
oui mais quand on quand on travaille sur
le complotisme et on sait que j'allais
dire il est très rare
d'adopter une théorie du complot on sait
que logiquement il peut y avoir un
glissement qui s'effectua assez
facilement
vers d'autres théories du complot
justement pour cette opposition au
système et ce raisonnement c'est à dire
tout le monde nous ment nous devons
trouver une autre vérité et
s'installer dans cette communauté plus
que ces petits que
selon vous valérie igounet ça vient d'où
la ce se ce côté on nous ment on nous
manipule on nous cache la vérité ça
relève du fantasme une opinion bien plus
forte que les faits comme comment vous
l'expliquer
j'ai à dire c'est plus compliqué
évidemment que sur certaines théories on
peut parler de chantage comme vous le
dites mais sa relève on voit bien au
corps j'allais dire aujourd'hui on parle
pas que du complotisme mais c'est vrai
que ça a été utilisé pendant la campagne
présidentielle comme vous le savez ça
relève évidemment
d'un système comme je le disais
précédemment on pense qu'on nous
manquons on trempe on ne croit plus en
grand chose on est beaucoup de nos
concitoyens sont plus que désillusionnés
dans la politique d'où aussi ce résultat
aujourd'hui et je pense que yayi est
plus que du scepticisme comme je vous le
disais tout à l'heure et qui peut amener
à une violence qui est
[Musique]
qui est plus qu à volonté et dans
certains cas prévisibles j'allais dire
oui il ya un vaudois héros c'est le
journaliste vieux briscards qui va aider
cette jeune journaliste a enquêté sur ce
qui arrive à son frère et qui dit que
qui dénonce une vision paranoïaque qui
dit aux complotistes vous donner du sens
à une situation complexe qui nous
échappe ça rassure mais les réponses
simples aux questions complexes
ça n'existe pas c'est votre vision aussi
de de cela
c'est à dire que c'est une facilité de
s'engouffrer dans la simplicité pour
justement
expliquer la complexité comme vous le
dites aussi c'est se rassurer mais
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas prendre cette
échappatoire alors quand je vous dis ça
c'est évidemment je vous parle pas pour
moi ou pour d'autres personnes mais il
faut aussi c'est ce qu'on voulait faire
tous les quatre c'est c'est compliqué de
juger ses adeptes du complotisme il ya
une mise en avant évidemment des
idéologues de la coupe aux sphères on
entre
l'instrumentalisation
de typhons preuves et qui fonctionne
mais il ya aussi ces personnes dont qui
s'engouffrent dans cette ce dos
simplicité parce que c'est facile aussi
de dire ça donc voyez c'est compliqué de
juger en même temps il faut mettre en
avant mais c'est vrai que je pense que
ça peut rassurer et on sait que ça
rassure le complotisme les voix
divergentes ratio et c'est très
difficile à combattre rien de vos
personnages qui explique qu'il faut
surtout pas condamner surtout pas y
aller deux feront face à un complotiste
faut s'y intéresser écoutez et détricoté
extrêmement compliqué ça c'est
extrêmement compliqué il ya énormément
quand même deux
structure de personnes qui essayent de
combattre ce complotisme des services de
cette news etc mais c'est vrai que je
pense que et on voit bien aussi le
désarroi des parents ce jeune homme et
j'ai justement aussi le désarroi de rose
cette soeur parce que si on combat par
l'agressivité on disait t'es qu'un nul
tu comprends rien etc il semblerait que
ça soit évidemment pas la bonne solution
et c'est justement
ce qui ne veut pas entendre donc je
pense qu'aussi la pédagogie c'est vrai
qu'on met en scène aussi un enseignant à
yanis rôdeur
comme je le répète ce n'est pas le
fictionnel il ya des fraudeurs existe
bel et bien et qui explique et danser
bulin que en fait quand il est devant
ses élèves il les écoute il les entend
il s'entend de même et il sait j'allais
dire presque un dialogue mutuel qui
s'auto construit et progressivement ils
peuvent arriver aux gones elle lui la
côte et à des coupures certaines
théories du complot mais c'est pas si
simple dans la réalité non et vous
montrez bien dans cet ouvrage merci
beaucoup valérie igounet je rappelle
donc avec jack schwartzmann lara et
morgan navarro vous signez donc cette
bande dessinée ils sont partout aux
éditions arènes bd savez en sortir c'est
dessiner c'est c'est con c'est comme un
film ça seul éviter bien rapidement en
un mot il y aura une suite
j'espère pourquoi pas merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité valérie igounet
et merci